it takes good Laing to raise a house like this
it takes good farming to have full vines full bill
good people of the solid old stock that
settled in this country 300 years ago
to last forever
or even here in this rich state
of Pennsylvania which has some
of the best farms and farmers in
the country trouble has crept in
all over the country there has been
trouble all of us meet and talk it
over talk over the deep problems of the land
and the people that no longer than anyone
one of the problems is erosion the loss of massage
it was amazing but the washer bring Kendra
oh please you're here once
and grass is higher than air
we found this in Tennessee but you can find it
in greater or less degree in every state please
devastated sod like patches of soil contain
the vital elements upon which all life depend